das ist ein absoluter gänsehautmoment
der raumfahrt und fast keiner hat ihn
mit bekommen vielleicht ein paar voller
von mir auf instagram aber an den medien
ist es zum größten teil vorbei gegangen
was für ein absolut beeindruckendes bild
hier steht die größe rakete die jemals
gebaut wurde das starship des weltraum
unternehmen spacex startbereit fast was
noch zu tun ist und warum so plötzlich
aus dem nichts aufgetaucht ist jetzt in
konstanz im future gibt es dreimal pro
woche faszinierendes science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst herzlich
willkommen
ich dachte nur bot zwar hatte ich die
arbeiten an der startrampe für starship
verfolgt aber als dann am superheavy
booster in den letzten tagen 29 rektor
triebwerke montiert wurden
und er dann auf das staates gestellt
gehoben wurde war ich doch bach und dann
das dasteht sieht die größte jemals
gebaute rakete mit daten muss man noch
extrem vorsichtig sein denn ständig
ändert sich etwas an den plänen selbst
einen mast betont immer wieder dass noch
nichts final sei und immer wieder etwas
geändert werde aber eins ist sicher das
ist absolut mind blowing warum sie jetzt
schon steht dafür gibt es einen grund
und auch dafür warum ihnen maske dort
jetzt ein großteil der leute von spacex
hin beordert großes steht bevor
aber von anfang an das ist das nächste
große ding von spacex die arbeiten an
der ecke 9 und der falcon heavy wurden
eingestellt um dieses absolut
bahnbrechende raumschiff zu bauen die
anhänger kippten werden noch einige
jahre starten aber das schiff mit dem
superheavy booster wird voraussichtlich
die allzweck rakete von spacex werden
mit einem riesigen transport von um kein
anderes raumschiff kann so viel fracht
und so viele menschen in den weltraum
transportieren schon mit der glut wecken
von spacex ist es möglich statt drei
menschen wie bei der russischen
sojus-kapsel sieben menschen ins all zu
befördern
wobei die grenze bisher bei vier
personen lag und das starship ist eine
vollkommen neue dimension
nach dem bisherigen daten kann es bis zu
100 menschen ins all bringen 100 auf
mehreren 640 einzelkabinen und
gemeinschaftsunterkünfte sind dafür
geplant
das ist der absolute wahnsinn man sieht
es auch an der größe 9 meter durchmesser
118 meter höhe
das ist lediglich acht meter höher als
die saturn 5 die apollo rakete aber die
obere stufe ist um einiges größer als
die der saturn 5 wobei es bei der saturn
5 auch zwei stufen waren insgesamt war
die saturn 5 dreistufig starship hat nur
zwei stufen damit das klappt hat das
starship zusammen mit dem superhit busse
die nahezu doppelte schubkraft 21 tonnen
gewicht kann das raumschiff damit in die
geostationäre erdumlaufbahn in 36.000
kilometern höhe bringen mehr als 100
tonnen in den low earth orbit in 400
kilometern höhe also zb zur
internationalen raumstation iss und wenn
das starship im erd orbit aufgetankt
wird können diese 100 tonnen bis zum
mars gebracht werden es ist damit das
erste interplanetare raumschiffe
astronauten und astronauten dafür wurde
das raptor triebwerk entwickelt das
starship und superheavy antreibt das red
dot triebwerk ist größer als das merken
triebwerk vom vergangen und hecken und
liefert so den doppelten schub anders
als beim erleben werden auch nicht
kerosin und flüssiger sauerstoff sondern
flüssiges methan und flüssiger
sauerstoff eingesetzt starship soll von
7 rektor triebwerk ins all befördert
werden der superheavy booster von 33
unter dem prototyp jetzt sind allerdings
bisher 29 raptor triebwerke montiert die
konstruktion passage ist ganz besonders
anders als ursprünglich geplant wurde es
nichts aus carbonfaser mischung gebaut
sondern aus edelstahl regierung die
fabrik in los angeles dafür wurde wieder
geschlossen und die maschinen entsorgt
mass zufolge soll diese umstellung einen
raschen und kostengünstigen bau
ermöglichen
zudem reflektiert stahl ein großteil der
infrarot strahlung der sonne doch von
der apa sagte wissen wir dass auch stahl
probleme machen kann diese war nämlich
sehr schwer und brach so zusammen
zumindest sieht die außenhaut so
ziemlich beeindruckende aus eine art
hochglanz politur als eine art
cool faktor soll sie wirken und die
entstehende hitze reflektieren was ist
sich sicher dass stahl das bessere
material für die höhle ist es ist
leichter und das wegen seines
verhältnisses zwischen stabilität und
gewicht der hohen
temperaturbeständigkeit und dass
deswegen geringeren bedarf an
hitzeschutz dafür wurde eine neue
raketen vor beginn dem kleinen ort boca
chica am südlichsten zipfel von texas
aufgebaut hier wurde auch die space ex
south texas lounge site eingerichtet
also das gelände auf dem jetzt das
starship aufgebaut wurde
der wichtigste erste test beim ersten
orbital flug wird der wiedereintritt in
die atmosphäre sein damit ein raumschiff
nicht wieder auf die erde zurück fällt
muss es im niedrigen orbit rund 30.000
kilometer pro stunde schnell sein und
diese geschwindigkeit muss zum einen
beim wiedereintritt wieder verloren
werden und zum anderen ist das aufheizen
auch unvermeidlich das raumschiff ist so
schnell dass es die luft vor sich
komprimiert und gas wird unter druck
heiß sehr heiß die runde form des
raumschiffes drückt die heiße luft wie
eine bugwelle bei einem schiff mit einem
abstand vor sich her trotzdem wird es
auf der oberfläche des raumschiffes
immer noch mehr als 1500 grad celsius
heiß
jetzt hat das starship durch seine
stahlkonstruktion schon mal einen
deutlich höheren schmelzpunkt als das
aluminium des space shuttles trotzdem
darf es auf keinen fall zu heiß werden
auch das special wird jetzt wieder space
shuttle mit hitzekacheln von der großen
hitze geschützt das starship hat den
großen vorteil dass es ziel indisch ist
und die kacheln fast alle dieselbe form
haben können was wahnsinnig wichtig ist
für die serienproduktion und damit
kosteneinsparungen die vielen
verschiedenen kacheln am space shuttle
waren wegen ihrer unterschiedlichen
formen eine riesige herausforderung
zudem wurden sie als raumschiff geklebt
so dass sie abfallen konnten was
ursächlich für die columbia -katastrophe
2003 war die raumfähre verglühte beim
wiedereintritt weil sich an der linken
flügel vorderkante ein hitzeschild
gelockert hatte deswegen werden
hitzekacheln beim starship auf
metallstifte gesteckt so können sie
nicht so einfach abfallen das problem
sind allerdings die speziellen
landeklappen und deren scharniere am
starship die sogenannten
londons nach ihnen mass benannt sie
müssen speziell abgedichtet werden das
nicht mit den hitzeschutzkacheln gehen
wird allerdings wird das durch die
stahlkonstruktion erleichtert laut mast
soll das mit metall möglich sein die
hauptfrage beim ersten orbital flug wird
also sein wird starship den
wiedereintritt unbeschädigt überstehen
und wird der superheavy booster exakt
landen dafür wurde eine ausgediente
ölplattform gekauft und zu einem
landeplatz umgebaut entscheidend ist
hier wie exakt landet der booster denn
später mal soll er nicht auf landebahn
aufsetzen sondern von fangarmen an den
startrampen aufgenommen werden und das
geht nur wenn der booster absolut exakt
landen kann
doch wann findet der orbital test statt
das ist die große frage und viele
beobachter vermuten dass die schnelle
montage der rakete druck auf die
genehmigungsbehörde die us amerikanische
luftfahrtbehörde federal aviation
administration eia ausüben soll immer
wieder legt sich masken mit ihr an wie
schon beim start des prototypen es
erneut
er twitterte über dfl im gegensatz zu
ihrer flugzeug abteilung in ordnung ist
hat die hauptabteilung der fr eine
grundlegende kaputte regulierungs
struktur ihre regeln sind für eine
handvoll einweg starts pro jahr von ein
paar regierungseinrichtungen gedacht
unter diesen regeln wird die menschheit
nie zum mars gelangen starship und harry
booster sind also startbereit wie es
scheint oder mass will zumindest den
eindruck entstehen lassen nur wegen der
wm wird es noch länger dauern bis der
staat auch erfolgen kann das dürfte dann
die nächste überraschung werden die
spannung steigt also also für mich
ehrlich gesagt bis ins unendliche de
mars stellt rakete für mars mission vor
starship kay one anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
also hier klicken oder auf den abo
button das ist kostenlos und macht
schlau
bis dann dran